[Music]
uh welcome to the big chill
seven dollars and 23 cents don't if you
tip me i have to sing
really we are 10 people okay
wait wait wait it seems like i made you
mad that's not what i want to do cause
baby me and you could go together like a
double scoop fine
you want me home after work perfect it's
a date it's not a date it sure sounds
like a day
so saturday here i'll pick you up at
seven it's a date okay fine but just
once and
it's not a day does this girl have a
name isabelle
one more one more
[Music]
me and my dad we try to formulate a plan
honor society student council
track blah blah blah is that what you
really want though
come with me whoa that's called my boof
of proof
let me see what you got no i don't rap
dude you're wasting time see you later
on i'm sorry man
look just because i know what i want
doesn't mean i always get it but at
least i'm honest with myself
what do you want i want to take you out
again
people do things when they're dating i'm
not dating darren you're gonna have to
leave do you even like me it's not that
simple everywhere i look i see you i'm
just chasing after something i have a
year to live if that
life goes on it moves like a
merry-go-hog you know it's not always
easy
but nothing ever is that's why we make
plans all right
let's run away i have a plan izzy we're
gonna live our full life all the
milestones all in this year
me and you go away darren i don't
believe in happy endings
believe in me one condition
anything you have to stop saying i love
you
you want folks to feel your music you
got to feel it first so what you got for
me
something but it's rough that's more
than most people
the only way to learn about life is by
living and i've learned that every
moment is your moment
if you can manage to look past your own
fears and everyone else's expectations
the reward is your life
[Music]
you